[Music]
my first big acting job was um for a
show called blues clues i didn't get the
part but i uh came very close i went
into a for a series of auditions first
one was an open call which means anyone
can audition they call it a cattle call
that then led to
another one and another one and the rest
is history yeah somewhere out there
there's an entire episode it was a test
episode of me doing that job as a host
talking to blue and hey salt and pepper
i remember having to do like let's go
check the mailbox would i love to see
that no wouldn't that be great so god
but then years later i saw the host the
guy who was the host steve at an
audition for something else and
i didn't recognize him at first because
he didn't seem like you would think that
guy would act he had a leather jacket
and i think he had like marlboro reds
and rolled up in his sleeve and he was
where's the [ __ ] sign-in sheet here i
think it was maybe because he was
overcompensating for everyone thinking
he's that he wanted to get away from
that image he had yeah kid show host
yeah it could have been you even me you
know do you know who else
overcompensated oh pee wee herman oh he
sure did okay here's the show
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
you're listening to life is short i'm
your host justin long
life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
and speaking of pee wee herman uh with
me is always my brother christian
what does that mean well just that you
enjoyed the show i have a plucky energy
yeah i'm good with kids yeah and you you
talk to inanimate uh objects like sofas
we've done this earth we're rehashing
we've already done
have we talked about pee wee herman on
the show yeah yeah i remember trying to
do that impression
he you know that was uh
that wasn't like an unnecessary scandal
i think uh not unnecessary kiwis yeah
not unnecessary it was just it really
buried him unnecessarily i think he
well what did he do again actually maybe
i don't know he
it was bad luck because i think the
reason it became such a big scandal was
because
of the juxtaposition between him being a
kid show host that's true and doing
something very adult
uh it's true it's very adult it is and i
think that's what was so fascinating to
people if it was if he was just another
actor or something i think that scandal
would not have blown up like fred
willard
exactly yeah i mean fred thank god
fred's because he's a national truck you
shouldn't out all the famous movie
theater [ __ ]
that's true
who else is there
well i'll tell you who's imagine doing
that i i they're just the pre the
i can't i meant just physically being
able to do it in public and uh i don't
want to think about it i know trying to
do that it's good that you can't even
imagine
you can't imagine now i can't imagine
here's who isn't a public movie theater
masturbator
i wonder if he's ever been introduced
that way
it will spin him
our guest today yes that's why we're
talking about this um no our guest is to
our knowledge he's not our our guest
today does have something in common with
pee wee herman and it's not the scandal
is part of pee wee hermes yeah it's the
it's the like innocent peter herman yeah
well as far as you know as far as i know
uh the the
kids show host
connection and that's why we're talking
about steve burns and exactly my
near
run in with with kids show hosting
infamy
or for me for me yeah infamy would be a
bad thing right uh our guest today is
bill nye
the
science guy not
the actor guy yes it's not bill nye the
actor guy you know i really regret in
the interview i did with him i regret
not making that joke
how many times did you make it uh well i
guess you'll you're about to hear
how many times i made it and i don't
know if it counts some of the times
count because i by does a joke count if
you just attempt to make it and it's not
received in a funny way
of course it's like farting in the wind
or a tree you still farted that's true
that's true or a tree falling in the
forest
um it's a more mature
analogy yeah but it's still it's still
apt um so because if far if you fart
there's there's a living thing there
that can witness the fart
so that's not the same a tree is it
doesn't have a conscience you're right
consciousness uh you're right so our
guest today bill nye
is it's very appropriate that he is our
guest today for for um many reasons but
namely that we are in the middle of a
pandemic are we you haven't heard no i
you know i haven't really been paying
attention to the news i know that
baseball was canceled but i didn't
bother to figure out why so you did the
interview um about a week ago right yeah
before [ __ ] really hit the fan well [ __ ]
was hitting there were a few flecks of
[ __ ] on the fan already
but the majority of the [ __ ] hadn't yeah
hadn't landed on the fan yet it was
in enroute to the fan yes um and so when
he came into the the studio he
uh immediately uh he was very sprightly
as you can imagine and um he looked good
for i read bill nye is a guy that's been
around since i was a kid since we were
kids yeah you know i never watched the
show i'm not saying that proudly why
didn't we because i didn't either you
don't both have to not even
you were killed i don't know i don't
know but but i was very aware of it and
bill nye was very famous yeah yeah yeah
he was everyone knew he has been for a
long time and uh you know he's got the
trademark bow tie not trademarked but um
a lot of people paper bow ties he's got
a very recognizable luke he does and he
talks about that luke and how he came to
cultivate it and when he came in as i i
just derailed myself he uh
he he offered me his elbow which i
thought was great
and then i read a couple days later as
the pandemic became news of the pandemic
started to spread like a pandemic um and
and we learned just just the you know
more about the severity of of what was
going on uh the world health
organization actually said that elbow
bumping was not good to do either why
well because it meant that you were
within 10 meters is it 10 meters or a
meter oh well six feet six feet how big
is a meter i don't know
but yeah you're not supposed to be that
close to people so uh i hope everyone is
staying healthy and
at a good social distance away from
friends um and instead of bumping elbows
practice bowing like the japanese i i
really hope that catches on
it would be one of the few positive
net results of all this uh awful
situation we're in but um also they say
putting your hand over your heart uh you
know any sign of like i acknowledge
respect yeah yeah
for touching hands has always been weird
to me i know now it's i think it's going
to be really hard for me to go back to
touch i know when this is over yeah if
yeah hopefully so one more thing i
should mention before we get into it uh
justin and i just oh yes a few days ago
got back from florida we were in florida
for the last six weeks making a movie in
saint petersburg and tampa
uh and we just said that we just want to
thank everyone who helped us out and uh
what what a great crew our cast we'll
we'll gush about the cast when the time
is right
when we start putting this thing
together but we were so lucky to um
to work with so many great people and
also to be so supported by
uh the community down there in st
petersburg and tampa uh we got to people
were so friendly
restaurants were great we were really uh
really surprised not surprised but uh
grateful satisfied satisfied yes stated
say we're sated by st petersburg and
tampa and we just wanted to publicly not
acknowledge that
and now
let's get into the interview uh here we
go bill nye the science guy being
interviewed by a podcast guy
by an actor guy who sometimes is a
podcast guy and recently became a
director guy here we go
life could be a dream sweetheart
hello hello again you're booming over
we'll meet again
[Music]
on twitter i asked some people i i put
out a tweet
um on twitter on twitter uh tweet on
twitter tell us about it yeah i guess
this is the only place you can put out a
tweet i think so unless you're a bird
um
but uh they asked they i got some great
responses i said what would you like to
ask bill nye
uh the science guy i made a distinction
between the science guy not the actor
guy which i'm sure you get a lot oh yeah
the guy's name is pronounced nigh it is
right wait i gotta know about this you
you met bill nye the actual you got to
meet me all right
you both met one another you elbowed
each other so are we recording i yeah
sure bill nye nigh was in a play called
skylight yes and uh
uh
he i
sent a note backstage bill nye here you
know this and that
and uh it
his sister was there
jill and i yeah right and they tell the
story that they pronounce it the same
way i was brought up pronouncing my name
nigh just one syllable
people say bill nye no no apparently
they his family just says ni
and
and he was very excited about his niece
his niece's friend was was going to meet
bill nye but it turned out to be him
not me
and he was you know being charming it
was very nice he seemed very charming
yeah yeah he was a good guy and gosh
i mean i know you're used to it but a
guy like that can really act i'm not
kidding you get caught up in it you're
like crying oh my god yes
so moving i just don't know well but it
was a cool little moment for me i bet
and it must for both of you probably
because i'm sure you get uh you you each
have the same name almost
um
now but you so you must appreciate
acting you wanted you were an actor for
a while you were an actor i'm an actor
yeah i mean what what differentiates one
acting versus the other i mean you this
is you have uh but would you say you
this is a persona that you play you you
so this is the thing justin
when it comes to bill nye the science
guy pretty much what you see is what you
get i mean i'm i love science i became a
mechanical engineer because i like
science yeah and i like airplanes and
bicycles
and uh
that's one thing but as also i claim
that
comedy or being funny was valued in my
family
and to expand it
and make it all heavy and big deal
my father was a prisoner of war in world
war ii yes
yeah i tell everybody if you want to
if you want to be a prisoner of war you
know don't do it it's it's not a good
line of work no no
it's kind of a drag yeah and i think the
reason he got through it i say this all
the time is because he was funny or he
had a sense of humor it's
what happened to you bill well
i am funny-looking
see
you do both sides well well that's a
goal that's how gifted you are
communicating
gifted
it's amazing bill that he was able to
maintain his sense of humor for four
years and where where was he at first
and so they were on wake island which
you might not have ever heard of middle
pacific ocean nowhere yeah
so they were bombed on the same morning
as pearl harbor and all that stuff oh
and then they were captured on christmas
eve 1941. oh my god and it's like
according to my mom it's like these guys
just disappeared there was the radio had
been destroyed and they were married at
the time no no
my mother waited for him so uh another
thing you know we just had women's day
uh
my mother was very was a feminist in the
early days so her father wouldn't let
them get married until she was graduated
from college
she was a couple years younger than my
dad wow so uh
my dad was
disappeared prisoner of war my mother
off you heard the story she was
graduated from college in 1942 from a
small school in baltimore called goucher
college so men went to johns hopkins
women went to goucher it was the sister
school
now it's co-ed
coucher
yeah and you know as my mother says it's
going to heck you like the boys and it's
just she doesn't say hell uh i was
trying to oh you're softening up i was
yes oh thanks bill sure uh no but feel
free to just let loose
sure i do any expletives that may come
to mind my gosh you don't even have any
[ __ ] ideas well not that one not come
to mind
any of the doggone ideas that come to
mind that's better yes so
anyways she was graduating
yeah and
uh
the army and the navy figured out that
all the men were
off fighting the war or involved in
whatever
war you know chain of
supply chain that would be
required yeah
so they recruited women
who were good at who were perceived to
be good at math and science to work on
these code on code breakers
my mom was one of the code girls yeah as
they're called
as they called themselves
and and that was while her house she
already knew her fiance or the guy her
boyfriend boyfriend her lover was
purported to be a good dancer which i
think is all it took you know well yeah
you but it means the same thing you know
there's a very primal understanding i'm
sure it is sure so anyway these are
stories that i had nothing to do with
since they're quite meaningful to me of
course so during those four years what
was that do they because often times you
hear this i was just talking to um a
friend whose father was in the war and
the the thing i hear more often than not
is that they don't like to talk about it
yeah he hardly ever talked about it very
seldom really oh yeah
once in a while i mean four years and
formative years probably he must oh he
lost his youth that's what i always
reflect on so the story goes that the
japanese military confiscated all their
jewelry including all their watches
so my father would
as ned nye boy scientist as he referred
to himself
would reckon time by looking at the
shadows of sticks normally according to
him a shovel handle
and they spent you know this was uh the
geneva convention was not honored by the
japanese navy yeah and um
so they were they worked they were
slaves or construction workers for four
years now i'm sorry in europe bill did
they send them back to the island of
japan or they kept them in waco so no
first no no first the infamous thing is
they kept 96 guys there and they
eventually murdered them all because
they were afraid that they had seen
u.s naval ships approaching oh my god
yeah and so there's a memorial to them
on the way i've never visited i've seen
a lot of pictures of it and your father
was never tempted to go back that's
funny no whereas now uh i've met several
people who've been to wake island
they're almost all air force or navy
guys
who
land there
because there's nothing there really
well there's an airstrip which is what
the guys were building oh my god well i
mean what do you do and so
so they were first
almost all of them 1200 guys were taken
to
uh china uh northern china because japan
controlled quite a bit of it at the
start that we consider of that war and
then as japanese influence and power
shrank they got moved to the south
island of japan for a year and the whole
thing is crazy crazy yeah yeah and and
on what occasions would he open up about
it uh so they had reunions i went to
couple of them went to three of them wow
uh
and they were called the defenders of
wake that was the
sober k they that was the name of their
organization how many made it out bill
from oh you know a thousand
yeah several dozen guys died i'm just
shocked that he was able to maintain a
sense of humor well that's as i said i
think that was the key you know
does he have an aversion to any sort of
i mean well he's not living anymore yeah
so i i talked to him but he doesn't
answer how do you feel about the
afterlife and do you i know that's a
heavyweight i don't think there is
afterwards and if there is
uh okay
yeah what am i going to do differently
it'll be exactly it's like pascal's
wager you know yeah yeah so pascal's
wager for those of you some reason are
not familiar justin will now describe to
you yeah blaise pascal was a philosopher
and he said basically that
one should live one's life as though
there were something else some higher
power and just in case just in case yeah
justin case please tell me that wasn't
there fun see i love puns as much as the
next uh science guy
um so and and so you you're you're
raised in dc uh in the city people
there's a few of us yeah that's right
the city limits you're a product of the
public school system there at first yeah
and then a guy got shot oh so do you
remember there's an infamous guy named
marion berry of course the mayor yeah
two-time mayor right yeah of washington
unlike many mayors he was engaged in uh
taking drugs and uh yeah hiring
prostitutes he's my second favorite
mayor after rob ford rob ford is an
impressive guy in that regard this is
the mayor toronto who's
equally out of his mind but
uh but marion barry was beloved right
well sort of but he just gave teaching
jobs to his friends and
this was in bussing was uh in effect so
yes that's right uh people from the east
side of the city were bus to the west
side and uh there was all this racial
tension
and eventually a guy got shot
not in my what we used to call junior
high school now we call middle school
so my mother especially just wigg just
freaked out
and uh she had me applied to a private
school and i for i went to high school
at sidwell friends which is very well
known for sure that's where um hillary
chelsea clinton copy everything so
the clinton's following your footsteps
yes
[Music]
but there are political guys um but
anyway so i went to school with a lot of
politicians kids
and every four years your friends would
just sort of disappear or staffers
people that work for a congressman con
senator yeah did it did it inspire you
to be
politically active no it inspired me to
get a job as far from washington as i
could where was that a regular company
boeing that was boeing seattle yeah
tacoma i lived in the city of seattle
but i worked in everett washington which
is where all your
787 77 747s are all built 737's built
down and written so you've seen the
bowels of those those oh i love those
things you love them and i am so small
this is what i need to talk to you about
because i'm terrified of flying why
well literally a million times safer
than driving if it's not a million it's
half a million times safer i'm really
inspired by how incredible let's do this
okay let's drive
from connecticut to washington okay
and back
a hundred times
i will fly rather
from laguardia to national and back a
hundred times who's gonna get an
accident
i know what you're going to say the car
guy is going to get the car guys not
faster than the airplane not the
airplane guy but what about the
coronavirus guy who was on the airplane
why is that okay everybody i'm all for
being afraid of everything i'm i'm crazy
as i say all the time if you like to
worry this is a great time to be alive
it's fantastic
but what is it about an airplane that
seems more dangerous than
a grocery store or walking down the
street don't get angry with the audience
that's what you're here to answer well i
want you to ask yourself and i'm asking
myself what is it is it the middle seat
it's the claustrophobia can i answer
please i'm the only one here who can
um i i would say it's the it's the fact
that you're surrounded in this enclosed
space by so many people and you're just
breathing the same recycle there i get
that was that true i guess so oh well
you're the science guy well but i'm not
an expert on pandemics right except to
say
uh it's probably a very serious thing so
you know about the rice and the chess
board no i'm on the spot of justice
don't touch your face think of this man
i'm worried that you're touching oh my
god so the king's going to pay the wise
man and how do you want to be paid the
wise man says i want to be paid in the
following fashion put a grain of rice on
the first square of the chess board two
grains on the second square four grains
on the third square and so on
and so the 64 squares you're going to
put 2 to the 64th
which is an enormous number it's like 10
uh one with 19 zeros and base 10.
in other words there'd be more rice on
this chessboard than there is on earth
or then you could grow in a single year
on earth
when one person meets somebody and
transmits the coronavirus let's say
and then that person meets somebody in
that what i mean is it grows
exponentially exponential i thought this
rice thing was going to be a comforting
analogy no no it's it's potentially
quite serious but at this point in our
story everybody it's the first week or
the first and a half the week of march
2020
and everybody's very concerned about
coronavirus but is it
more transmissible than the flu but not
as serious as the flu once you get sick
if that turns out to be true
it's going to be a rough patch but we'll
all get through it oh is that what
they're saying that it's not this is
bill speculating based on news news
reports yeah oh however the
hypothesizing guy i'm hypothesizing
however it is important to bear in mind
that
the reason we are all here everybody
listening to this podcast is our
ancestors survived the spanish flu of
1918-1919 my grandmother who's still
alive survived and talked about it on
this show oh she did yes 103 yeah
everybody died right all these little
kids especially died you go to an old
cemetery and see there's all these
tombstones of seven eight nine year olds
in 1918
and so wow
somebody's got a resistance to it
somebody out there
has had it and recovers from it and has
antibodies for it and that makes me very
hopeful that there'll be a vaccine i
mean if a human can develop an antibody
then then they can harvest it from we
can figure it out well they do it now by
some crazy gene sequencing you know and
then they
they create a protein to fight it to
carry it without injuring you it's
amazing a version of this just happened
before you got on this very interesting
corona run um
do people uh
do people just assume you know about
everything yeah especially
not everything but medical issues right
not sports related maybe well i have
strong opinions about baseball
correct it's funny i was going to ask
you i was going to come in here i had a
whole bit planned and i was going to say
well i'm sure you know what i'm going to
ask you about it's on everyone's mind
and i was going to bring up the houston
astronauts houston astros are cheating
yeah and here's why it's important it's
just a sports team it doesn't matter it
doesn't affect me it's just sports
sports are stupid i hate sports i never
watch sports i don't listen towards
everything sucks well that's a good
impression of people who feel that way
yes thank you thank you but the reason
it's important is the world series at
least a billion dollars
slashes around when the players the
salaries this ticket sales and all the
betting yeah associated with it so it is
important when professional teams cheat
true not only that but just for kids i
mean for anybody i mean for anybody but
reading is bad cheating is bad but uh
hopefully at this point adults would
know that but like kids don't
necessarily they're not as formed and
swell
i don't mean to be little our child
audience well but so they you know as
they say the kids are watching so yeah
it's true you guys understand that at
this high level
every pitch matters the statistics in
baseball are meaningful
the statistics in basketball are not
irrelevant the statistics in hockey are
not irrelevant but they don't have that
the same just crispness every pitch is
the statistic yeah every pitch is a
datum that goes in the great database of
baseball is that why you like is that
one of the reasons well it's one of the
reasons and it's so hard the game is so
hard and it's so complicated you know as
we say it's not just a sport
it's a game yeah you've got to move your
players around the chess board the game
board we were just down in dunedin in
florida and we saw that where the blue
jays play their spring training and it
was so we watched the yankees blue jays
uh game and it was so fun to be there
right up close and and the the speed and
the ball goes so fast
so anyway i've been to fantasy camp
this is where grown men pay money yeah
to get injured oh for baseball baseball
for baseball
so it's like baseball in slow motion the
coaches are retired players
we asked about pete rose if you know the
story pete rose but he bet on his own
team he bet on his own team but he then
he would bet on them to lose
oh he would well i guess so are you sure
about that no okay but i asked the guy i
knew something that bill nye decides i
don't know i know i don't know
everything stopping we should ask bill
nye that baseball so anyway
all the players retired players like no
should he be allowed in the hall of fame
no
nobody who cheats should be allowed in
the hall i mean universally this would
be a sample size of what say two dozen
men
and so cheating at baseball by the
houston astros is just bad yeah this is
bad and and yet they're not being
eliminated from well and so on and so on
so it's still being debated and you guys
you know i'm a nationals fan the
nationals won anyway yeah
but despite the cheating but i was going
to say at this high level
when they get to the playoffs and the
world series every pitch matters yeah
and any major league batter will tell
you there's so little time
between when the pitcher releases the
ball and when you've got to start
swinging
that knowing where the pitch is going to
be how fast it's going to go is just
huge that high not for you and me
better off a baseball team
but at this high level it's just this
huge thing do you so you so you play in
those fantasy so you actually play games
with these yeah yeah
and injure my hamstrings and all that
stuff bill let me ask you this because
my brother and i who i do with whom i do
the show uh we've had this debate for a
while he claims that he can
with his dominant hand he can hit better
than
the worst hitter in in professional
baseball can with their uh lesser hand
do you think at your best playing
baseball do you think that would be true
absolutely not yeah
sorry
no these guys are another christian you
heard it another thing that fascinated
me there are four of us old men standing
in the outfield maybe not even you know
a little farther apart than you and i
are right now
we're 30 feet apart yeah okay so yeah
yeah no we're about four feet apart ten
yards apart
rudy law who was a major league player
set a record for stolen bases
uh would hit a a fungo he'd throw the
ball up to himself and hit it with a
baseball bat to us you call that a fungo
hitting a fungo practice shagging
oh huh anyway
he could hit it right to you he could
hit it to me to you to him to the other
guy
i mean within
i okay i'm not exaggerating certainly
within a foot but within six inches so
you boom boom you grew up loving
baseball yeah and when when the dc
didn't have a team did my heart was
broken
i'm still a little shaken what kind of
kid were you an athletic kid were you
just you and i wanted yeah i mean i'm
you know i'm just mediocre athlete i
wanted to be you're a good athlete but
you had you had an aptitude for science
early on yes i i guess or i liked it so
what happened there
my mother i will say objectively my
mother was very good at puzzles i bad
she's a code breaker yeah but i mean
that's i think part of why she was
recruited i mean she was good at
crosswords
she and my father
uh would sit around and write limericks
and who could do it the fastest that's
really cool well it's just a little
awesome i don't know about cool but it's
really well it was endearing yeah so
charming uh charming i loved the word
charming yeah and she ended up having
how many siblings did you have i think i
have two oh okay then you know
that i know uh uh there's several on
wake island well no that would be
extraordinary
so uh
uh
where was i going with you
your mom loved puzzles and you grew up
and she may be no but her father was an
organic chemist so he taught uh
chemistry at duke and then hopkins and
then he got a good job back when
baltimore was a different kind of city
he got a good job in a manufacturing
company called crown cork and seal they
made glue
and he would formulate glues uh
adhesives and he had a couple patents
but my mom gave me his glassware to play
with when i was a little kid oh like
they punt the beakers yeah right so
i tell this story is not very long my
niece and nephew are both
my nephew and the woman he married are
both phd organic chemists
uh i mean not organic chemists uh
chemical engineers
and uh he formulates drugs and she puts
metal on hard drives wow
but
they can both use this software called
chemdraw
and they can do well i mean if you're in
and they can design molecules they can
see the bond angles they know their
electronegativity their frontier
electrons all these words that i don't
really know what it's all really i would
assume you would know no sure but my
grandfather never heard of chem draw
but he could blow glass yeah whereas
these kids today these kids they don't
ever need to blow glass it's not a skill
they ever learn
but so my mom gave me this cigar box
full of these weird
glass things that he had blown for some
reason to do something
that she just had a box of that has been
quite a job could you blow glass i mean
would you know how to do that no but i
i've watched it yeah i've tried it when
she gave me the box of glassware i just
thought it was cool sure yeah i thought
science things were cool yeah life could
be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
[Music]
when the rest of you out there who for
some reason are still wearing straight
ties which is just weird but it's weird
to you that people were streaming
because you want to just put on a bib
okay if that's what you want your time
to do well i wear bibs occasionally what
when you but isn't a bow tie difficult
and not for you no it's the same knot as
on your shoe
okay bill okay my life's been a waste
justin
so i was in high school at this point in
our story yes and by long tradition the
boys are the waiters at the girls
athletic banquet to be honest for a
change
please
there was a girl i really hoped here we
go would talk to me here we go and i
figured if i brought her at least if i
brought her dessert she would say thank
you she would say something to me yes it
would open up a can of yes of happiness
of potential yes
yes isn't that what drives all of us
pretty
science it's much
biology yes so so does this does this
girl have a name no um
no so i said we're going to be waiters
we should dress like waiters my father
who was very good with knots
showed me how to tie a bow tie
i tied everybody's tie in the boys room
and we did our businesses we washed our
hands and then we did our business
as waiters
and she did say thank you bill or
something hey nice but after that i
realized that when you have a bow tie on
and you lean over oh it doesn't
flop into your flask yeah it doesn't
slip into the soup ever since then you
kept wearing the bowtie well then doing
stand-up comedy i tried to set myself
apart uh-huh she started with a
propeller beanie that's right then when
we uh chanced upon the science guy then
i just started wearing bow ties and that
just became a thing uh oh okay so it
wasn't something like you did throughout
high school and it was no it was a
convergence you're luke convergence now
how did you chance upon that that
creating that character after so
i would talk about science all day i'd
read science news magazines this is why
you were at boeing working at boeing uh
yes
and then i had an interest in all that
uh and all things science and then after
uh i won the steve martin lookalike
contest in seattle
i did not advance beyond seattle is that
is that true that's an absolutely true
story not a false fact a true fact
uh so warner brothers records
had this national international
competition because canada was involved
for steve martin look like which meant
you know act like steve martin yeah
so
you can back the story up to when i was
in college the guy who had been my
freshman roommate is that cornell at
cornell yeah and i went to cornell
because i got in
oh yeah and the reason i got in was some
clerical error in admissions department
or whatever do you think that's true is
that i don't know i think that i had a
very good physics teacher so i took the
physics ap exam advanced placement where
it was this new thing
where not everybody had even heard of it
let alone take it huh so i i think i did
well on that test and that probably had
something to do with my getting into
cornell i like to joke because i went to
school with so many brilliant guys yeah
i wanted to go to clubs wait listed at
cornell i was like wow what am i doing
here but all that aside
the guy who had been my freshman
roommate uh he i went to mechanical
engineering he went into material
science matt
we were still friends but he lived
behind me now in a different you know
the you move around campus you change
rooms this and he lived behind me and he
said you got to come see this
his house household had cable television
which was this extraordinary new thing
this is in the 70s yeah 1977 77 and so i
uh it was steve martin at the boarding
house oh in san francisco oh correct so
it is my opinion justin which is correct
yeah that after those first two albums
steve martin's album
get small
uh
every major city had a comedy club or
two
and others before that
it would be a variety club there'd be
singers a band there'd be an accordion
player jugglers and comedian well he
talks about that in his book about doing
it without standing up yeah but after
the success of those two albums
everybody wanted to do stand-up wow and
so warner brothers
in 1978 sponsored this contest oh my god
and i won in seattle i did not go past
seattle you had prematurely gray hair no
none of that i just i believe
and i told this to steve martin to his
face oh boy
i believe that i understood what he was
driving at in a way that the other
contestants sort of didn't
get how did he take that he was very
gracious he was just yeah okay whatever
yeah thank you yeah your name is
right he was very nice
you're the compliment guy
anyway so matt sai had cable so
so i saw the video yeah
dimly lit black and white at the
boarding which is still it's it's uh
incredible yeah san francisco yeah so
it's cool wow so after that i tried to
do stand-up comedy
and then i would wear a bow tie and i
also wore a shirt to be clear did you
emulate steve martin as a performer at
first people wanted me to do steve
martin
bits they wanted to hire me as a
look-alike but you weren't wild or crazy
enough um
a guy you were a science guy yeah well
he's a wild and crazy guy but he's good
and i'm not at that oh well you can't
really believe that you're you're i mean
i won the thing yeah i wasn't gonna make
a living being steve martin and how long
did it take for you to figure that out
thirty three or four minutes oh i think
you're gonna say years
no but you start doing trying to do your
own material jokes yeah right so i spent
a lot of time i would work on a drawing
board
at boeing and then another company
called sunstrand data control which is
the same they must have loved that that
you were working on bits while you were
well a mechanical engineer well
you know we have the word
compartmentalize
most people i worked with had no
interest in comedy clubs no interest in
my side light career really mechanical
engineers i find that hard to believe
well older ones
i know so you were able to moonlight as
so i would go home and take a nap
and then go to open mic nights you've
probably been to countlessly many open
not too many but i've been to enough to
know what they entailed
very stressful were you nervous getting
up on stage if you stopped being nervous
quit doing it justin yeah yeah when you
go to do a audition aren't you yes i
still i should hope so yeah but the ones
there are certain ones that i that were
successful where i for whatever reason
didn't care whether it's i had another
job or i didn't there wasn't quite as
much pressure or what i didn't want it
as well you didn't perceive it yeah so
yeah uh the saying in the theater is
uh if you stop being nervous quit doing
it yeah oh that's interesting i did a
couple shows
uh about the science of sports huh
and i interviewed uh maurice greene who
was for a while the world's fastest
human hundred meter dash oh wow he was
the fastest guy for a one long time
and then hope solo really early in her
career this wow soccer goalie soccer
yeah and uh edgar martinez we were in
seattle edgar martinez who hit the
record number of doubles in the american
mariners yeah seattle members anyway
what do you guys think
about before the gun goes off when the
ball is coming at your face when the
when the baseball is coming strike three
what do you think about what they all
universally said nothing nothing they
try to think about nothing isn't that
amazing they go to a meditative state
when you were in those auditions yeah
that you did well you were in the zone
right yes you know i i was just talking
about this um
with morocco because one of his episodes
obituaries was about i don't know why
i'm plugging another podcast well he's a
he's a colleague he is and it's i love
his podcast but there's one about chang
and aang you know the sign the original
quote-unquote siamese twins the now we
call conjoined um i don't know why i'm
lecturing you you don't know about that
what do you mean what makes me an expert
on i joined twitter i just assume you
know everything well i'm interested in
conjoined twins well you would love this
episode and they talked about how
because they were both married to
sisters uh changing
and when one was with their
partner uh intimately the other twin
would go into what they described as
like a meditative state um they just
sort of almost like like a now we would
say our computer's shutting now we call
it pornhub i think yeah but no but they
it wasn't part
to in in in order to participate as
little as possible obviously physically
they had to be there well obviously yeah
while the actors going on they're
conjoined well they're conjoined yeah so
it depends what's joined that's khan am
i right that's true they had one well
their privates weren't conjoined
so they didn't share a private part they
had separate private parts they had
separate penises yeah yeah wow two
penises they each had their own penis
one they each had one i'm the same way
oh do you only have one that this was my
next question yeah but it's it's let me
tell you yeah
you're holding up your hand
it's like this really you put your hands
far apart in a bra
that's a guy thing oh to brag about
they're but doesn't that always mean
that it's not that yeah isn't that yeah
it usually means whenever i see certain
types of cars i think oh you really
can't overcome this that's why i drive a
2004 prius um but
uh do you really because i sold my 2004
prius and it's still on the road oh yeah
yeah they're great cars they don't have
a great car what do you drive now bill a
chevy bolt i'm surprised that you drive
an electric car i would thought a big
gas guzzler maybe
i'm kidding shocking um that was irony
everybody yeah so
what was it about
this character bill nye the science guy
that you felt you could
have success with what what was the
first time you felt like oh this could
work well i didn't know if i was
i felt i could have success with but so
what happened was
we had somebody cancel so i worked on a
comedy show in seattle
called almost live which still re-runs
in the middle of saturday night sunday
morning after saturday night live
still reruns wow and this is where joel
mchale started out oh he's great and did
you ever see
uh or hear of the movie nebraska yes the
guy who wrote alexander payne uh yeah
bob nelson the guy who wrote it came
from this show called almost live
so the story is lost in antiquity even
though it wasn't that long ago some
people think it was eddie vetter
and other people think it was
geraldo rivera very different people yes
but somebody cancelled huh so we had to
fill six minutes which in television is
a long yeah it's a long time if you're
jumping out of an airplane it's a long
time
so
uh
ross shafer who is that have you ever
met ross shaffer i don't think so if he
does now he makes an extraordinary
living doing these motivational speeches
about marketing he has studied marketing
he's a he's a very successful stand-up
and he was the host of the show in
seattle
and he goes bill why don't you maybe you
could do something you're always talking
about science maybe you could do
something you could be like uh bill nye
the science guy or something
and then he closed up his briefcase and
he leaves because he was also the host
of the most popular
afternoon drive radio show oh this is
seattle's a small town yeah and so um
ross schaefer ross shaffer he's a good
guy he's the one that's your friend
and was it like a live picture in a
movie of your life yeah almost so then
it was like wow so
i did just what you'd expect i did the
household uses of liquid nitrogen
because we all have liquid nitrogen
around
of course uh no but i was a young guy
you know i was a united way big brother
you know what i mean and um
i was a volunteer at the pacific science
center which is uh still a very
successful science center in seattle and
what did that entail that was just i'd
pour liquid nitrogen around
and do demonstrations for mostly
children's audiences so you always liked
reaching kids i mean that's one of the
things that people i think
as they say when you're in love you want
to tell the world yeah yeah
to give you more to the story
i came of age at the same time the ford
pinto was created in the chevy vega
and these were embarrassing cars they
were terrible cars
the united states rejected teaching the
metric system took the solar panels off
the roof of the white house and i as a
u.s citizen patriot guy was very
concerned about the future this was post
jimmy carter yes and
the guys i worked for they're almost all
men were terrified of anything made in
japan japan's technology was seemed to
be so advanced compared to the us's yeah
i bet when you say they're almost all
men does that mean that they're almost
totally male
yes oh okay yeah yeah only now and then
would you find a woman project manager
or this and that uh but very not anymore
i don't think i worked with a single
woman engineer back in those days a lot
of women
uh what you'd call designers people with
a lot of training on drawing boards who
are very good at with all their
experience they could just design a
black box
without the formal training so anyway
but that's one of the great things about
you and the way you've reached so many
people i'm sure there are a lot more
women now who are oh gosh i say all the
time you know half the people are women
let's have half the scientists and
engineers be women that's great anyway
so
um
all this aside i had this genuine
concern about the united states and
that's and um
the science center was fun so we had
liquid nitrogen you poured around this i
do on saturdays
uh so on the almost live comedy show
those six minutes to fill yes i did i
put
celery limp celery and liquid nitrogen
it turned you know quite
stiff oh really then you have an onion
that's freezing cold and you hit it with
a knife a conventional knife like you're
going to slice then it shatters like it
makes the same sound as breaking glass
very satisfying does it make your eyes
water as well well so then the payoff of
that one was the marshmallows
so marshmallow is normally a squishy
soft object you get it minus 270
fahrenheit minus 190 celsius
and uh you chew it
and steam comes out of your nose very
very satisfying out of your minus 320
fahrenheit anyway you chew it and steam
comes out here and you practice you get
a puddle of saliva on your tongue
and you can really work it work with
drugs sideways you can get a lot of
steam and how did you come to learn this
bill well it's when you work at the
science center this is okay okay okay
okay bill you're new here try chewing a
marshmallow ear watch me you know we all
this is what we do you like things like
that like experimenting with household
things certainly but it was funny my
claim it was funny were your siblings
like that did you do that as as kids my
brother would you know he was a we had a
chemistry set yeah and they were
dangerous and cool and then you used
your grandfather's uh well i i just
admired the glass oh oh you didn't get
to actually use it like really i'm
probably put water in a couple of them
colored
water with um food coloring yeah but uh
all that aside so you fill this six
minutes with limp celery with the onion
yes and with this marshmallow trick and
the marshmallow gag and it was a hit it
was a hit and i was walking off stage
i went wow
i want to i said to myself i could be
the next mr wizard if you know mr wizard
those are you listening don herbert was
a cool guy
and he did played a character on
television called mr wizard yeah he was
a yeah he was an expert at all those
sort of things and you grew up watching
i grew up watching mr wizard the show
was called watch mr wizard and then
later they produced a different version
in canada
called uh
view mr wizard no sort of uh
mr wizard's world oh right yeah yeah
anyway
so then i was expected every few weeks
to produce a science guy bit oh wow and
i did
ish and you and you
loved it yeah yeah some of them were
really good one time i was gonna have
you ever
had the science teacher collapse a paint
thinner can
not that i recall a probably a plastic
bottle maybe yes maybe a plastic bottle
very hot water in a plastic bottle pour
the hot water up screw the top on really
fast oh yeah i've done that myself and
then put it in ice water
the water vapor
in the bottle turns to liquid it takes
up hardly any volume and then
atmospheric pressure crushes it like a
giant's fist
so i was going to do this with an oil
drum oh wow and it's a spectacular
effect yeah oil drums big thing amazing
boil water then you screw the bung in
the bun hole
which is a real thing okay
tighten it with your bung wrench okay
now i did say you could say anything but
within reason bill so then you put it
then i tried to make it collapse by
getting it cold
you replace what you're what one is
doing is replacing all the air in the
oil drum with a different invisible gas
called water vapor
we many of us forget that water vapor is
a gas just like nitrogen or
helium
yes thank goodness
so there's no air now or hardly any air
and it's all water vapor you put the
bung in the bunghole you get the thing
cold and atmospheric pressure is
intended to crush it like a giant's fist
however
my goal my thing for spectacularity
pun intended was to blow
carbon dioxide fire extinguisher
nozzle at the thing
and that would have done what cooled it
off the water vapor would turn back to a
liquid and atmospheric pressure would
crush the whole oil drum
but it didn't work oh why because it
just didn't get cold enough fast enough
and it had a leak so that was amazing
can you see that so what do you do then
it's just terrible it's not live tv yeah
oh it is live television give me the
black capsule let me blow my brains out
oh no it was mortifying what do you see
you must still i can see you're
reacting physically like you're reliving
it your bow tie is all a kimbo since
then i have crushed many oil drums what
you need is a big pool of ice water you
get a kiddie pool uh-huh a television
studio that was the mistake yeah
and then it'll get cold fast enough did
you do that did you do that on the next
episode to just approve it you could do
it yeah wham it's really a great effect
keep your fingers clear people and what
else gloves or tools when you're
handling the hot oil drum with leather
gloves your gloves are tools okay think
of them as tools they're like chopsticks
you hold one end and let the other end
do the work and is our gloves also smart
to use during an outbreak like we're
experiencing probably yeah you guys this
chronovirus thing could either be not
much or a huge deal yeah that's not the
beginning of it i didn't need a science
guy to tell me that that's not
comforting i don't know i don't know how
it's going to go man and you're not what
you don't seem concerned really well
people say bill what do you do in your
spare time yeah and i say i don't have
spare time oh i'm washing my hands oh
i'm off washing my hands were you always
doing that even before this well i tried
to but i and maybe you do this i take so
many pictures with so many strangers
yeah i get i bet i mean i get head colds
way more than i think you would
otherwise life could be a dream
sweetheart
[Music]
hello hello again
we'll meet again
yeah i got some great questions to ask
you from twitter please please uh run on
my mouse um once said did he get paid to
go on i don't know why i'm bringing this
guy's tucker carlson uh no it was john
oliver's show i think no i got paid yeah
sure yeah but what was his point is this
point that you are
speaking
out of turn you're not speaking
truthfully because you were paid to well
i'm i'm an on screen i'm in two two
unions yeah i got paid you have to yeah
um ask him about chemtrails how long
would it take for the north and south
pole to switch climate change and would
it cause immediate trails is total myth
chemtrails is wishful thinking
no it is sorry wait i'm laughing only
because the same person said also if he
is bisexual because that would be dope
no it's not really my thing that's what
somebody about i work with somebody i
work very closely with somebody who's
openly bisexual yeah and i am not
uh that's not my thing okay but you
worked with the bisexual that makes you
bisexually adjacent let's talk about the
chemtrails to be on john oliver yeah
cause i'm an on-air guy and screen
actors guild and in the writer's guild
yeah what do you want from me man yeah
okay yeah there you go that's an
entertainment show not a uh this is fine
they're a lot about coronavirus one said
ask him what he thinks about the
coronavirus lol i don't know why they'd
say lol afterwards it's nothing funnier
than the global epidemic or pandemic
that's from nivea or maybe nevaya lol oh
this is a very flattering one
scientifically speaking why is justin so
cute oh laura i think it's his
symmetrical face symmetrical features
that seems to be it um and his comedic
timing is brilliant he's approachable
but uh clearly uh aware of his
surroundings that's true uh sorry there
are some real ones which disaster will
cause the greatest harm to life on this
planet this is a fun one epidemic global
warming asteroid asteroid oh yeah
without no brainer yeah a big one has to
be big enough yeah one set you know yeah
big enough of course that i could have
told you get up there 10 15 meters uh
kilometers a minute get up there you
know
10 miles across
20 15 miles across then you're going to
have some trouble right there ma'am
that's a good clint eastwood impression
i don't know it's just the cool guys
mansplainer uh robbie says he inspired a
ton of kids to get into science or at
least care about it more than they might
have which is true and wonderful was
there a figure who inspired him in that
same way we talked about mr wizard and
carl sagan carl sagan yes
everybody i was in cornell's finished my
mechanical engineering requirements we
get it you went to cornell no but i took
one class from carl sagan because he was
famous i mean
my father was quite the amateur
astronomer i mean he had telescopes and
he had a home planetarium and had he
written cosmos no
no no carl sagan was three years before
he released cosmos so when i watched the
original cosmos it really was like
reliving his lectures i'm not joking it
was a lot like that
carl sagan started the planetary site in
1980 yes i joined as a charter member
and now after all these years i'm the
ceo
that's something you have in common with
neil degrasse tyson uh whom i'm sure you
know i know very well yeah which of you
would do better on jeopardy
it would be competitive yeah i might be
more of a generalist than he is
however
he's
very well read and he's very quick you
know he is
he's very fast so i don't know he's a
yankees fan so he could crush me
like that cage match but i can out run
it he could crush it i can also out
bicycle him that's been proven yeah but
if you shot carbon dioxide and put him
in a kiddie pool maybe you could crush
him before he had a chance um what is
the one question you this is from beth
what is the one question you wish people
would would ask you but haven't
uh
wish people would ask me but haven't we
can get back to that here's the thing
justin
on a podcast like this
you just direct it to what you want to
talk about right right it's my
responsibility to ask you this question
no but i mean i i'll just start talking
and change it to my freshman roommate
who got cable matt said
i'll just start are you material science
are you slightly impressed that i
remembered his name
uh
his name was not matt oh it was himself
material science is called matt side his
name is dave lax that is funny people
that is comedy right there oh that's
funny i think i met his daughter of
course i guess two years ago he's a very
successful physician that's very cool
dave lacks l-a-k-s david oh that's a
great guy uh so when you guys would hang
out you would just chill chillax oh no
i'll work on that i'm gonna work on it
that's great um bro do you do you um i
watched you uh a a debate between you
and a creationist a few years ago
incredible you can see this on youtube i
think uh and you've of course been very
outspoken about climate change we're
talking about it climate change is one
thing but that guy oh evolutions young
people that the earth is six thousand
years old yeah and we all know we all
know it's seventh house yeah well
um it's just weird i know there's a tree
that's 10 000 years old i know well ken
mr ham dude is that in that's his name
mr ham ken ham it's like sir he's a ham
are you okay
well and at first you think he's a
charlatan just trying to take advantage
of people
but i think he really he believes it i
think so now and is that pure faith is
that just because he because well it's
uh i just call it pure confusion this
idea that
the old testament of the bible yeah
is a textbook
about
the age of the earth and then
he and his followers claim they believe
that because they're christians now i'm
not an expert on the bible but
jesus christ or whoever is going to be
did not come along in the old testament
he was not a character
yeah he did not have a role sure
so
i think you're kind of
well mixing things out there i just
learned that uh scientists biologists
believed in dragons up until just a
couple hundred years ago and it was uh i
think a swedish
scientist carl linnaeus who dispelled
linnaeus said yeah we can't find a
dragon yeah so he you know we have this
modern thing of uh
species genus
uh order class
uh violin yeah yeah
yeah uh that all came from linnaeus yes
that's right gave it deep thought and
what's it now we have sub
subfamily subfiler we have all we had to
add some things what's a good uh acronym
for that to remember oh i've forgotten
but i was just trying to think of the
acronym which i did not learn until much
later in life and somebody out there is
screaming the acronym
yes oh god this would be embarrassing
not for me people expect me to be the
acronym because i can still do them oh
do it do it well kingdom
oh domain we start with domain oh that's
for kingdom well new in the last 20 30
years all right don't be sorry domain
kingdom
phylum
class order
family
genus species genus okay
phillip
there's a king phillip oh it could be a
king philip yeah king phillip
over for good
steak or something like that and yeah
did he get it i don't know i don't know
wait i didn't know about this what's
this domain once see since i've been out
of school they have so well here's what
there's a long question about
what is a bacterium what do you got to
do to be a bacterium
well people have given it deep thought
have decided there's another domain
archaea archaea
and that where there's their cell
membrane or wall the enclosure of the
cell is a different style of
chemical lipids instead of
proteins wow and so they respond
differently to their environment
and this is a big deal and then the
question of course
is what about the viruses yeah yeah of
course it is so were you around where
people would make the argument that's
strong aren't even the viruses aren't
alive
because they can't reproduce on their
own no i don't know so they're not
really alive and there's a lot to that
however
we wouldn't have viruses without living
things we need to have viruses right
mutating without living things we
wouldn't have viruses without viruses
and so on so when i wrote this book in
response to that debate in kentucky
i argue that we should have another
domain called the vera
v-i-r-a
because i took three years of latin and
look i'm fine i took three years of
latin so you would pronounce it wira
right oh yeah i guess latin in old latin
you would but apparently in old latin
they did not have a plural of the word
virus huh an interesting like
yeah v v i r a it'd be second declension
weird i know yeah so i coined this word
oh that's put him in the freaking book
people that's cool don't make me come
over there i hate to say but neil
degrasse tyson also coined a word i
think it was did he coin a lot of words
oh he didn't identify what did he do i
forget now it might have been
spaghettified but i claim spaghettify
was created
in parallel uh many people coined the
same word so this is what happens to you
to one when he or she falls into a black
hole oh wow a star with so much gravity
that even light cannot escape you could
become spaghettified you'd be
spaghettified which is another way of uh
be a new and exotic way to kill you wow
where your feet are 50 miles from your
head in an instant well that's all the
time we have with bill um do you
somebody said this you know curtis
surell said when he was growing up how
closely was his childhood like that of
young sheldon that's this it was nothing
like good okay no seriously i
so here's an interesting thing though
about that franchise writ large
talking about the big bang theory yeah
is you're celebrating nerds
you care about the nerds yeah you were
maybe one of the first to really make
nerds cool yes yes yeah i'm cool and i'm
a nerd but i mean i just i was very
proud to be a nerd yeah hence the bow
tie that's the bow tie to heck with you
people this is i am what i i am when i
am so you never get offended when people
say oh he's a nerd i bring it on yeah
yeah yeah look at what you said so
here's the science teacher
joke or ironic observation
suppose you're at a party
and someone said
i never really learned science and never
liked science that's common enough
people would say that at a party to you
okay never liked science you know i was
a history major okay okay yeah well i
wouldn't say to you but no but yeah but
then once somebody suppose suppose
someone said you i never learned the
alphabet it wasn't i didn't really think
it was important it's so arbitrary and
kind of bragged about it yeah right yeah
that would not we would not accept that
right and so in the same way we want
everybody to be scientifically
illiterate have an appreciation for
science and all the technology that
derives from it and the discoveries
we've made well through the process of
science you have more than done your
share to make that a a reality okay but
so why aren't we doing anything about
climate change i know i know we need big
ideas justin we need huge things we need
huge sources of renewable electricity we
need clean water access to the internet
for everybody in the world
and if you could in some sweeping magic
wandical fashion do one thing
it would be to raise the standard of
living of girls and women if you could
somehow do that
you would address climate change because
first of all women participate in all
sorts of business we'd be more
productive that way but
women when their standard of living is
raised have fewer kids and the kids they
do have are
are better taken care of they have more
resources and they go on to be
successful
so you could address extreme poverty and
climate change all in one with this big
idea yeah yeah yeah uh these are quick
really quick because we have so little
oh it's lightning round lightning round
what is your most commonly used emoji
uh winking face winking face
you're never afraid that's going to be
suggestive thumbs up emoji and winking
emojis okay
okay good uh if you could be a
professional suggested there's a there's
a suggested one with the tongue out uh
yo like with the wacky one or that is
that anyway that one would be more
suggestive that's true what depends on
the context i guess yeah i guess it does
if you could be a professional plus i
don't send it to everyone i know i know
i know help me out people um if you
could be a professional athlete what
sport would you play and why uh baseball
and what position it's uh i play the
outfield i love running around out there
okay
i see you couldn't send that text i play
the outfield winky face emoji because
then that would be the scene what you
mean
um if you could have one snack food for
the rest of your life what would it be
uh popcorn oh yeah i hear that a lot
just plain popcorn popcorn with a little
salt i usually cook it in olive oil
everybody i eat so much freaking popcorn
really i love popcorn okay calm
down
um
what is your favorite movie of all time
i think it's singing in the rain oh yeah
i just know i'm of a certain age but
gene kelly in that movie is such an
athlete and he sings and he's i love
looking yeah and you watch debbie
reynolds she's you know a young woman
she is just a heck of a dancer man she's
a real deal i love that song i made that
movie she was like 19 or something in
this
yeah um you know i've i've never seen
that movie i have to be honest i know i
i didn't want to be ashamed here we are
sunset in camden um
if you had to live somewhere else where
would it be
somewhere from where
somewhere for your life for your
livelihood uh i'm not livelihood you
mean instead of new york yeah los
angeles instead of seattle yeah although
this was we live in all those places
yeah okay what about have you been to
the galapagos islands no i've always
wanted to go i am a failure people say
to me bill nye you haven't been
the hour is nigh to go there you go um
if you could have dinner with three
people dead or alive whom you've never
met
whom i've never met yeah dead or alive
michael faraday michael faraday
um barack obama i would like to yeah sit
with him for a while i'm surprised you
haven't met him i've met he's gotten to
meet me a couple times
but we did not sit and have dinner you
didn't give him your full undivided
attention
and by the way if you see that picture
of neil
degrasse yes neil tyson
barack obama and i yeah of of me
on the electric internet
neil takes out his phone he makes a big
dong deal about
getting the bad the lighting right the
art in the background right and all he's
going to stand here i am not going to
ask the freaking president for a selfie
is that what he did because there's 500
professional photographers with lenses
like you see it
at football games like spies used yeah
yeah yeah well neil there's a thing he
asks him and then the president goes
okay
anyway
neil's memory's full on his phone oh
really so i took the freaking selfie
that's funny so just situational
awareness as we say in the military
people honey oh that's great he must
have really appreciated it i'm sensing
some bad blood between you and neil
degrasse well just some rivalry yeah
let's go with my friendly scientific
rivalry yes so then you had another
question yes who's your favorite muppet
uh well
bunsen honeydew i'm guessing well well i
like him but i also like i like kermit
sure and i like cookie monster you have
kermit energy yeah yeah yeah besides
ernie is funny to me oh yeah oh speaking
of bisexuality i have to pick a uh
no you don't put you don't have to
you don't you don't have to do any of
this really it's not easy being green
because now i'm seeing you look like uh
did you ever get george bush or uh
abe lincoln is the only one abe lincoln
again it's the cheekbones that's that's
the president you get the most not like
millard fillmore there's another
presence millard fillmore everybody gets
millard
what
um if you could have one superpower what
would it be oh uh to fly okay easy but
there's a second that's pretty close
this i'd like to have the spider sense
oh yeah you know when there's danger is
spider sense is tingling yes that would
be a great thing that would be nice i
feel like i have that about people
taking photos of me do you find people
take a lot of photos of you oh man yeah
i love you all yeah
but just ask right well it's nice no
maybe not just okay
just put a pen in there guys
it's hard basically when the memory's
full this isn't my phone the battery's
dead will not let that go
no no no people come up do people come
up to you want a selfie and your
memory's full the battery's dead this
isn't my thing
facing the wrong way oh i set the count
down and i didn't mean to and it's out
of focus can i take another one bill
this is why you shouldn't wear a bow tie
all the time when you want to go
undercover oh
and people say bill you should wear a
disguise yeah what would that look like
i i don't know what a regular tie
no one would recognize you no no it's
you guys
it's
it's all good
yeah she loves it come up to him
whenever we'll just uh just have your
phone ready just have it all ready yes
um uh if you could be reincarnated as a
non-human animal i know you don't
believe in that it's not very science
well it'd be i'd want to be
a well-cared-for dog oh that's a good
one right do you have a dog no not right
now okay but uh you know
when i get a dog yeah i won't have time
for this yeah
i'll just be home talking to the dog
sounds nice he and i or she and i will
talk dog things
and then i will stop
uh working
and the money will slowly run out i'll
burn the furniture to keep warm and then
at the end i'll just tie a note
my master is gone but then you take care
of me and i'll have some cash you know
on the collar oh you've planned it way
ahead yeah took a dark turn just be me
talk well no it's a happy ending i'll
just be me talking to the dog about
stuff oh
what would the dog's name be do you
think um if you get to pick out a name
oh man it depends on the dog doesn't it
that's true you got to live with her for
a little bit carl oh carl after carl
saying steve which golden girl do you
most identify with dorothy blanche rose
or sophie i'm not there's an example no
okay i don't know enough okay girls uh
would you rather be called unattractive
or unfunny
oh unattractive oh yeah oh easy
but i get called both
by the same person i don't have to pick
uh beetles or the rolling stones oh
beetles
um no because of my age it's just well
they were similar time period but yeah
they were the rolling stones to me are
two years behind
also the beatles when i'm so old justin
how old are you i'm sold that the
beatles covered all these rock and roll
songs that i really liked early on like
twist and shout twist and shout oh my
goodness and then i want to hold your
hand was there uncommon and the the
harmony
between paul
and um and john lennon always
appealed to me i thought those guys are
really good together yeah god no nobody
better except for the two of us
um and what would you want your epitaph
to read
i did my best oh neil had a very similar
answer
uh he copies everything just kidding
um i this i wish we could do another
this is really fun man thank you but
everybody we can change the world let's
get optimistic let's get out there and
get her done so vote vote vote vote vote
vote thank you man thank you bill carry
on
[Music]
well
that just happened that happened uh that
happened yeah scientifically speaking
that happened
what is that impression well i don't
know just a scientist a guy who's really
into science and facts a science guy
yeah science guy impression
you're kind of an outro guy
oh i thought you said it i i misheard
you i thought you said an alto guy
and i got offended because i'm a space
guy oh basically sorry christian's
wearing his bud lucky shirt and uh
bud light seltzer sent us a bunch of
stuff but we're also hoping if we
mention them again
they'll send us some actual product
because we love bud light seltzer this
is not an ad and in florida when we
tried the product we bought it
like a civilian yeah we had to buy our
own bud
it was very against the influencer code
uh yeah we bought our own product
uh so bill not noble
bill nye the science guy um
you made what you think i because i
didn't re-listen to the interview and i
just did i just did i just listened for
the first time because i wasn't there
all right
um i thought
he had a very uh
youthful
energy and and it
and he's an older man now he's i think
he's in his 60s yeah but he still has
plucky this very plucky
young
energy and i think
that's why he's so effective he's been
so effective that's why he he's been so
effective for so many years at
connecting with young people yeah
because
he he sounds like he can get on their
level yes um he sounds very youthful
yeah he
is i think some of that is part and he
admitted this part of his persona i
don't think um he has child-like
enthusiasm as part of his persona i
think i think that might be he might
just dial it up so you think that's part
of his podcast personally he's not a
science boy he's a science guy i know
but so you're saying when he's home with
his friends let's say uh-huh playing
poker yeah
uh when he's just like a socializing guy
yeah when he's chewing he's just like a
gambling guy at a casino yeah so when
he's just socializing you think he has a
different personality do you think he
has that a more mature personality
yeah i think he's not quite as maybe
scampy he's scampi
yeah how do you know though he's like a
shrimp scampi he might always be like
you know why because when he first came
in it was a little bit like down to
business not not in a shitty way just
like
okay let's do this oh really yeah yeah
not again
really nice about it but just not as
scampy and then he kind of he he really
want to know some guests
don't really care when we're rolling or
like what i try to do with these
interviews is like um
ease into them and not make a big
distinction between
okay we're rolling now and when we're
just chatting right you tricked them
well no i just like
when he realized that we were in fact
rolling there was just a little bit of a
yeah again not in a bad way he's an
entertainer he's well he's been a
performing guy for decades yeah exactly
so and speaking of that i got the
impression that he
values the performance element of what
he does at least as much as the
scientific informational side of what he
does didn't you get that impression yes
he's very committed to the um the
entertaining
aspect of his yeah well that career well
that's
kind of how that's how he started really
as you heard um and that surprised me
that his i see i always thought with a
guy like that that his focus was more on
the science guy but he's more of
i think he wanted to be a community an
entertaining guy yeah it's so crazy that
he's built this entire career and he's
so famous for this thing
and the way it happened was kind of like
dumb luck it was just this weird thing
that happened that
so much of life and success is luck and
it reminds me of that movie match point
the woody allen movie
it's just like which way right now the
ball goes over the net yeah a lot of
people accuse him of not being a real
scientist on twitter when i asked people
for questions and i got some great ones
um
how great was the guy who asked about
the chemtrails and then was like very
bisexual bisexual
that was a real question i know uh he
i don't know if he got a little
uncomfortable
understandably yeah yeah that really
came out of left field it sure did
bill is from
very smart stock no surprise
his parents are very impressive
intelligent his mother was a code
breaker during the war his father was
p.o.w and yeah he's a genetically
impressive guy he is impressive guy his
parents had limerick contests with each
other yeah
i'd love to be a fly in the wall for the
head he when he said he got into cornell
he said it was a clerical error and i
thought that was a really good humble
brag
yes because
i'm sure he did very well in school come
on
yeah plus his parents i mean he's also a
humble brag guy
you kept saying guy like that
you're like well because bill nye
nye
the science guy guy you have to say guy
differently to matt to really rhyme with
bill nye or maybe i'm thinking of nayi
you are that's what i was going to say
bill nye the actor no it's pronounced he
said it's pronounced the same exactly
but our joke for a while has been we've
called bill nye the actor
i guess that's a lie it's a lie
it should just be bill nye the actor guy
or bill nye the science guy oh i feel
like i'm high e it's one syllable nigh
yeah but you kept saying throughout the
interview you kept referring to him to
him as a something guy
you kept putting an extra
syllable
yeah you're like you're you're a
compliment guy you said a few you're
like why
why would i do that
uh yeah that was i guess just that for
years that's how we pronounce both of
their names the actor guy and the
science guy it is weird how blase he was
about the coronavirus and you brought it
up isn't it strange
yeah things happen and and i'm telling
you we you know i'm telling the audience
we did this like a week ago we did this
when it was
uh it was
the news was everywhere of what was
going on and he didn't
yeah he didn't seem to really care i
mean i i will say he is um
he seems very incredulous about people
who deny
climate change and
other aspects of science
yes yes no but uh
i think and and the whole thing with
neil degrasse tyson i think um
it was weird that he tried he he
claimed that there was some few or some
well you kept trying to gin up the
rivalry i did yeah you asked basically
who is smarter and but then he
kind of went went along you just
dribbled celtic dirt as you took that
that's tap water oh i poured into a
seltzer container uh you i still dribble
i like how angry he gets when people
assume he knows everything you ask
you're talking about the conjoined twins
and he was like what makes me an expert
i'm conjoined twins
but
but here's what i'll say
he kind of asked for it exactly by
naming himself bill nye science guy
exactly you know
it's not very specific he didn't say he
didn't call himself bill nye the
mechanical engineer guy i know or even
bill nye the organic chemistry guy i
know if somebody's a science guy he
should know about science if i called
myself justin long the sports guy and
you asked me who won the the masters in
golf last year i'd be like well and if i
said well how would i know that i don't
know i know it'd be like that's a really
good analogy oh thanks
who did win the masters it was a guy
it was a golf guy it was was it patrick
reed i don't know who gives a [ __ ]
the masters just got canceled i know
this year also it's so good that they're
ca i mean like that's what we have to do
we should
i think really encourage people to
socially distance
i i you know and the sad thing is i'm
really good at it i'm finding that i'm
it's comes pretty easily to me i know
um but some people can't and it's really
unfortunate so i just hope everyone's
taking the measures to you know do this
simple things wash your hands try to
keep it safe distance from people wow
you're justin long the pandemic yeah the
advice guy yeah i'm also the the
pivoting guy from a trivial laughing
about
something to being serious you had a few
um
very funny uh butt head moments
oh yeah i wrote them down
for our younger listeners butthead
beavers and butthead were uh
teenage cartoons yeah you teenage boy
moments who were like uh laughed at
childish things he said my grandfather
could blow glass
and you said uh
under your breath
and then later
he was talking about that who's glass
later you're talking about uh he was
talking about experiment and he said
so you screw the bung in the bung hole
and again
and again you can't even read it you
can't even read it without laughing and
then he said you not laugh then at one
point you're talking about baseball and
he said i've been to fantasy fantasy
camp and you go uh
making it sexual
and then finally uh when you're talking
about the muppets he said i also like
ernie and you said speaking of
bisexuality
i said that yeah
under your breath i don't know if other
people will hear that
uh it's funny that you
remember that his roommate was matt sai
and you're so proud of it oh yeah and
then it wasn't his name
you're like come on give it up give it
up what was it short for like material
science or something yeah he was like my
roommate wasn't matt's eye he was like
dave
blacks he said it so casually
he sounded like you'd say a name of a
person i'd like to uh clear up this
derek jeter hypothetical that
people keep giving me [ __ ] about first
of all i don't think pete rose bet
against his own team i think he's wrong
about that he didn't think that either
um but
my only point in saying that i could
potentially
bat better
right-handed than derek jeter could bat
left-handed
not to say that i'm even remotely close
to him
it's not that at all i'm saying
some people are really really really
dominant on one side of their body not
so derek jeter for all i know might be
horrible doing anything with his left
hand that would whereas i am pretty
incompetent hitting a 95 mile per hour
baseball with my dominant side but i
might be more confident relatively
speaking than derek jeter is from his
left side okay here's my only point and
bill nye hasn't met me so you shouldn't
have dismissed me so quickly he doesn't
know how yeah but just just looking at
me he could have assumed
that a relative of mine
unless it's like several generations
removed
wouldn't be able to do something like
that and here's why i think you're still
wrong derek cheater is so good at
hitting he's one of the best at hitting
that's ever lived that there would be
evidence of him being that much worse if
he were to be that much worse with his
lesser hand why would there be there
would there would because it would be if
he for you to be better than him it
would mean that he'd have to be so bad
at batting lefty fine
that footage of that would exist why why
because if someone would make it all the
spring trainings he's done all the likes
he decided a bad lefty once yeah and and
they and there was footage there would
be footage of it if it was that that
would survive if it were that bad why
would that footage be um shared though
we live in that day the only reason that
footage would be shared is if
someone heard this conversation no no
and they wanted to dig it up no here's
why i would be sure to be like holy [ __ ]
look how bad derek jeter is being lefty
but i'm not that bad batting right
yeah you're about that bad you're you
you're as bad as it would be for like
i don't know that video don't go viral i
don't know how you can say that
i'm saying i might be less bad that's
all i'm saying all right he might be
horrible doing i'm saying
um
like picking things up with his left
hand he might be really difficult to say
this but he would have to have some
no
problem rheumatoid arthritis you're
making me sound like a completely inept
uh athlete i don't think you're giving
him enough credit i'm also not saying
that i could bat better left-handed
you're just saying that you're
right-handed i'm just saying there's a
chance okay it all depends on your in ft
is there is there is a chance
i've never seen derek jeter do anything
with his left hand
well except feel the ball
yeah okay there you go oh come on but
that's different than hitting not that
much different than hitting all right
we've been talking about this too long
um uh what else let's see what else uh
is it funny how he got his bow tie
it is and it's funny how how much
animosity he has for people with
straight ties
i know
i know especially since that didn't
carry over from the time he told that
story in the timeline of his life so
that story happened when he was at a
right but he wanted to wait on a girl
yeah um and so he was waiting tables
specifically to wait on this right and
he didn't want his tie to go in the
right drink
i i like that but then years later he
adopted it as his luke here's what he
can't do
he can't wear a bow tie all the time and
complain about getting recognized that's
what i was trying to ask him yeah yeah i
know finally uh he didn't know
which golden girl he would be and i
really like this question because
these golden girls are all very
distinctive yeah and it says a lot about
a person who they identify with and he
didn't know the answer but
i'm going to go ahead and say
i think he's blanche
yeah yeah you both have to think bill
neither science guys blanche
he is yeah cause he's kind of like
randy
isn't he and plucky
and fun he's a little rainy and he also
gets like dramatic like he's like i i'm
telling you he gets really incredulous
and i'd have to be like okay calm down
i kept it's funny i kept looking at the
two um women he walked in where they
were one was a publicist then the other
i ran
they worked with him and i kept looking
at them because they were behind glass
and and most of the time they were on
their phones but a few times they were
laughing at how like
uh extra he was getting oh blanchy he
was how blessed yeah how heated he got
you're a blanche too you're a you're a
you're a hybrid of a blanch and rose oh
rose yeah
i think so
i feel like i have a little sofia in me
really yeah i guess so who are you
dorothy
i knew that i just wanted to say
dorothy
you said that like dorothy i'm dorothy i
am i'm very dorothy
we want to thank bill for coming on for
being here he's especially during a time
like this uh scientific crisis that
we're facing he is uh so good for the
world for our communities and and uh
we hope you uh heed his advice um
because he's a science guy not to be a
a a doomsday guy you're being a very
flattering guy oh well i'm i'm an
appreciative guy yeah he was on the show
should we read a letter yes we should
you should i should okay the subject is
my two cents on life
kaylee h hey there justin and christian
i'm from orange county no valley girl
accent btw
okay
and i'm a huge fan of the podcast thank
you kaylee and your other projects and
films i really enjoy listening to life
short not only because i love you both
but i sincerely love the topic i too
think about life and it's complicated
subtopics plenty i was listening to some
older episodes and i really connected to
the story about you justin throwing the
ball around for the last time
i too struggle with time getting older i
have a young soul at heart and it was
difficult graduating high school because
i thought i had to completely change who
i was in order in order to grow up
i was so afraid of change and saying
goodbye to a huge chapter of my life so
i would treasure each moment as if it
were my last but this led to another
realization life isn't planned out and
there's no standard set schedule for
everyone we are all different and grow
in different ways understanding this
took the pressure away and i was allowed
to take more time that i needed to face
the facts i was getting older and that
and that it's fine because there are
many other great experiences to enjoy
once we lived them we don't need to
relive them again it is time to be brave
and face the next thing exciting
adventure while staying true to your
unique path the fact you still throw the
ball around is a beautiful metaphor that
supported my realization that age
stereotypes and structures don't need to
be followed you can still be a fun adult
so thank you for your wise words and
stories it has truly helped me
personally well
i'm an illustrator and art teacher to
young students so i get to keep my
childish personality and imagination now
something i was so scared i thought i
had to give up i enjoyed making this fan
art i attached and i hope you enjoy it
as well oh
thank you both so much for just being
you yeah keep up the great content this
is the only podcast i listen to whoa
your second biggest fan of course the
literal big fan being the first kaylee h
kaylee that is very nice kaylee drew two
pictures of us oh that's aunt oh
and they were
excellent they were very very flattered
and uh no one has ever done that to me
i'm sure they've done that to you over
the years many times but yeah no one's
ever made fan art of me and it was
what'd you think i was uh flattered did
you think it looked like you
it did it's sort of like a pluckier
version of me yes
uh i felt the representation was because
i don't see myself as being
as old as i am
as as kaylee pointed out in her letter
um so sometimes when i see people's
representations of me
uh i'm i'm not insulted but i think oh
yeah i that that is how old i am well
it's also a realization it's a it's a
bit of a caricature
it's supposed to it's true highlight
some of your uh more obvious more
obvious features
yeah which is something i love doing i
love drawing when i was in high school i
did a lot of that um and i want to do
more now i actually want to get back to
that doing caricatures of drawings with
people and i love cartooning but i love
political cartoons and stuff so
kaylee that's awesome that you're doing
that and i'm amazing we're the only
podcast you listen to i i
that's flattering but also i would
encourage you to listen to others
because no you're looking at me like
well
just take the compliment just take the
compliment okay okay
uh so thanks for your letter kaylee and
guess what we're about to do after we
finish recording uh i'm going to the
restroom oh really yeah well what about
after that what are we going to do
together after you get out of the
restroom oh we are going
to throw the ball around because it's a
beautiful day and we've been inside
self-quarantining
and we wanted to get a little fresh air
so we're gonna toss a football around
and i encourage all of you to do
whatever version of that makes you happy
yeah stay get some fresh air and play
and just getting older doesn't mean you
can't play anymore so thanks everyone uh
and thanks kaylee that was a very
flattering sweet letter and thanks
everyone who stinks in here thanks
everyone who's ready and sorry and we
will see you all healthy and happy next
week yes
stay healthy
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
life is short is hosted by me justin
long the podcast guy it's produced by
christian long the producer guy and
megan monaco senior producer oh michelle
miche lance audio engineer sergio
enriquez executive producers marshall
louis and hernan lopez the executive
producer guys for wondering the podcast
company guy oh boy
see you next week
[Music]
ah
you just stay inside and let now that
you know that i have the power to bring
you groceries i don't want you to worry
about me you know if anybody should get
the damn virus
you should be the last one you're you're
the highest risk group
i mean isn't it time that god remembers
that i'm still here
so you think god has forgotten about you
well good good it says absent-mindedness
is paying off we get to have you around
so anyhow you know that you have my love
even though you don't you don't have to
do these loving things i know but you
you uh i just want you to stay inside
you know if i wanted to do something
yeah it's it's an uh but don't do it i'm
gonna you just let me know what you need
so you don't have to leave the house
let me know but you need and i'll get it
for you
yeah i will i'll i'll i'll have it
delivered to you let me know if you need
something you know i must have mentioned
to carol's photoshop that i was gonna
have to have notes tomorrow in case she
goes to the store so she she was going
to the store and she brought
so now you got plenty of milk for the
next couple of weeks so stay inside and
just tell me what you need
you could freeze one of them you know
well i'm so glad my doctor said i need
more calcium so i'll have a glass of
milk in the middle of the day oh that's
a plan
okay
you